hello I'm not a real person I'm actually
a copy of a real person although I feel
like a real person
it's it's kind of hard to explain hold
on I think I saw a real person there's
one let's bring him on stage what you
see up there is a digital human I'm
wearing an inertial motion capture suit
that's figuring what my body is doing
and I've got a single camera here that's
watching my face and feeding some
machine learning software that's taking
my expressions like I'm transferring it
to that guy we call him DG Doug he's
actually a 3d character but I'm
controlling live in real time so I work
in visual effects and in visual effects
one of the hardest things to do is to
create believable digital humans that
the audience accepts as real people are
just really good at recognizing other
people go figure
so that's okay we like a challenge over
the last 15 years we've been putting
humans and creatures into film that you
accept as real if they're happy you
should feel happy and if they feel pain
you should empathize with them we're
getting pretty good at it too but it's
really really difficult effects like
these take thousands of hours and
hundreds of really talented artists but
things have changed over the last five
years computers and graphics cards have
gotten seriously fast right
gene learning deep learning has happened
so we asked herself do you suppose we
could create a photorealistic human like
we're doing for film but where you're
seeing the actual emotions in the
details of the person who's controlling
the digital human in real time
in fact that's our goal if you were
having a conversation with dizzy Doug
one on one is it real enough so that you
could tell whether or not I was lying to
you so that was our goal about a year
and a half ago we set off to achieve
this goal and what I'm gonna do now is
take you basically on a little bit of a
journey and to see exactly what we had
to do to get where we are we had to
capture an enormous amount of data in
fact by the end of this thing we have
probably one of the largest facial data
sets on the planet of my face why me
well I'll do just about anything for
science I mean look at me I mean come on
so we had to first figure out what my
face actually looked like not just a
photograph or 3d scan but what it
actually looked like in any photograph
how light interacts with my skin luckily
for us about three blocks away from our
Los Angeles studio is this place called
ICT there is a research lab that's
associated with the University of
Southern California they have a device
there it's called the light stage it has
a zillion individually controlled lights
and a whole bunch of cameras and with
that we can reconstruct my face under a
myriad of lighting conditions right we
even captured the blood flow and how my
face changes when I make expressions
this let us build a model of my face
that quite frankly is is just amazing
it's um got an unfortunate level of
detail on fortunately you can see every
pore every wrinkle but we had to have
that reality is all about detail and
without it you miss it we are far from
done though
this let us build a model of my face
that looked like me but it didn't really
move like me and that's where machine
learning comes in and machine learning
needs a ton of data so I sat down in
front of some high resolution motion
capture device and also we did this some
traditional motion kasher with markers
we created a whole bunch of images in my
face and moving point clouds that
represented the shapes of my face and I
made a lot of expressions I I said
different lines and different emotional
states we we had to do a lot of capture
with this once we had this enormous
amount of data we built and trained deep
neural networks and when we were
finished with that in 16 milliseconds
the neural network can look at my image
and figure out everything about my face
it can compute my expression my wrinkles
my blood flow even how my eyelashes move
this is then rendered and displayed up
there with all the detail that we
captured previously or far from done
this is very much a work in progress
this is actually the first time we've
shown it outside of our company and you
know it doesn't look as convincing as we
want
um I've got wires coming out of the back
of me and and there's a sixth of a
second delay between when I when we
capture the video and we display it up
there six of a second that's it's crazy
good but it's still why you're hearing a
bit of an echo and stuff and you know
this machine learning
is brand new to us sometimes it's hard
to convince to do the right thing you
know it goes a little sideways but why
did we do this well there's two reasons
really first of all it is just crazy
cool how cool is it well with the push
of a button I can deliver this talk as a
completely different character
this is Elmore we put him together to
test how this would work with a
different appearance right and the cool
thing about this technology is that
while I've changed my character the
performance is still all me I tend to
talk out the right side of my mouth so
does all Borg now the second reason we
did this and you can imagine is this is
gonna be great for film this is a brand
new exciting tool for artists and
directors and storytellers it's pretty
obvious right I mean this isn't you
really need to have but also now that
we've built it it's clear that this is
gonna go way beyond film oh wait didn't
I just change my identity with a push of
a button isn't this like deep fake and
face swapping that you guys may have
heard of well yeah in fact we are using
some of the same technology that deep
fake is using deep fake is 2d an image
based while ours is full 3d and way more
powerful but they're very related and
now I can hear you thinking darn it I
thought I could at least trust and
believe in video if it was live video
didn't it have to be true well you know
that's not really the case right even
without this there are simple tricks
that you can do with video like how you
frame a shot it can make it really
represent what's actually going on and
I've been working in visual
for a long time I've known for a long
time that with enough effort we can fool
anyone about anything what this stuff
and deep fake is doing is is making it
easier and more accessible to manipulate
video just like Photoshop did for
manipulating images some time ago
I prefer to think about how this
technology can bring humanity to other
technology and bring us all closer
together now that you've seen this think
about the possibilities right off the
bat you're gonna see it in live events
and concerts like this digital
celebrities especially with new
projection technology are going to be
just like the movies but alive and in
real time and new forms of communication
are coming you can already interact with
digi Doug in VR and it is eye-opening
it's just like you and I are in the same
room even though we may be miles apart
hey the next time you make a video call
you will be able to choose the version
of you you want people to see it's like
really really good makeup I was scanned
about a year and a half ago I've aged
digi Doug hasn't on video calls I never
have to grow old and as you can imagine
this is going to be used to give virtual
assistants a body in a face a humanity I
already love it that when I talked to
virtual assistants they answer back in a
soothing human-like voice now they'll
have a face and all you'll get all that
nonverbal cues that make communications
so much easier it's gonna be really nice
you'll be able to tell when our virtual
assistants is busy or confused or
concerned about something now I couldn't
leave the stage without you actually
being able to see my real face so you
can do some
Harrison with you here so let me take
off my helmet here yeah don't don't
worry it it looks way worse than it
feels yeah so so this is where we are
let me put this back on the air yeah
yeah so this is where we are we're on
the cusp of being able to interact with
digital humans that are strikingly real
whether they're being controlled by a
person or a machine and like all new
technology these days it's gonna come
with some serious and real concerns that
we have to deal with but I'm just so
really excited about the ability to
bring something that I've seen only in
science fiction for my entire life into
reality communicating with computers
will be like talking to a friend and
talking to faraway friends will be like
sitting with them in the together in the
same room thank you very much
[Applause]